want
good morning I will call the fiscal
committee meeting to order February 16th
Tu
morning
ah great
good
morning committee will
24072 great well good morning uh
chairman Wier and members of the fiscal
committee appreciate everyone taking
some time
today so today I come before you to
request authorization of expenditures in
the amount of $850,000 to allow New
Hampshire to send members of Our
National Guard to Texas to fac
facilitate security activities at the
Southern United States border to protect
New Hampshire citizens from harm the
funds will enable the deployment of
volunteers from two New Hampshire uh two
New Hampshire National Guard military
police units totaling up to 15 soldiers
to deploy to Eagle Pass Texas for a
duration of up to 90 days so let me be
clear the crisis along the southern
border is not just a Texas issue it's an
issue that affects every state New
Hampshire included and it's one that if
left unaddressed will continue to
deliver harm for families across New
Hampshire New Hampshire is fortunate to
have made Headway in recent years in
curbing the opioid crisis but the tragic
reality is that this year 400 families
will lose to loved one because of
fentanyl that is Flowing across our
Southern border record amounts of being
smuggled into our system since operation
lonar was launched by Governor Greg
Abbott in
2021 Texas alone uh their law
enforcement has seized over 450 million
lethal doses of
fentanyl in visiting with members of New
Hampshire's National Guard stationed at
the border just this last year I saw
firsthand the humanitarian tragedy that
is unfolding the enaction of President
Biden is on Full display I've met with
the men and women of border patrol who
want to do their job but who have been
told not to enforce laws that are
currently on the books simply P put the
southern border has devolved into a
corridor for the cartels to funnel
Fentanyl and Other Drugs into this
country fueling an epidemic of overdoses
that that has absolutely ruined lives
including lives right here in the great
state of New Hampshire open borders
invite additional threats of terrorism
and human trafficking so since writing
to you earlier this week some have
questioned whether the use using State
funds for this manner is prudent others
have questioned whether State funds
should be on the table given that border
security typically falls to the federal
government members of this committee
have said that this is a federal issue
and not a state issue and I could not
agree more the president and his
administration have the tools to manage
this crisis in their hands today yet
they have done nothing which is why the
states are stepping up in the absence of
a willingness at the federal level to
secure our borderers states must under
undertake efforts to protect the safety
of our citizens and that's more than the
Biden Administration has done in three
years working in coordination with the
Texas National Guard and the Texas
department of safety the work done by
volunteer members of the New Hampshire
National Guard to enforce existing state
and federal laws will have a life-saving
impact our teams will work uh will do
work that uh will likely include Manning
static security points and roving
patrols to identify illegal immigrants
and drug trafficking activities which
will then be reported to the Texas
department of safety for the uh
Interventional activities placing
obstacles and designated locations along
the texo Texas Mexico border conducting
land clearing operations in prep
preparation for permanent fence
construction um these efforts will
assist Texas in securing the Border
making criminal arrests protecting
citizens and helping limit the dangerous
drugs from reaching New Hampshire my
request to you today aderes to state law
which allows for expenditures with your
consent in instances in which action is
called for on an expedited basis to
combat harms to the safety and the
welfare of the state I urge you to
ignore the politics surrounding this
crisis and focusing on simply addressing
the humanitarian crisis at hand stemming
the unchecked flow of drugs into our
country drugs that make their way to New
Hampshire and take the lives of Granite
State Staters is incumbent on us all I
thank you for your consideration of this
request to protect the well-being of
granite Staters um and happy to take any
questions any questions from committee
members representative Edwards and then
represent lean uh thank you Mr chairman
uh thank you governor for uh considering
my question um would would you would you
agree with me that the situation along
our Southern border may actually be
more dire than what you've described
here this morning I I I I put what's
happened to the millions of people
coming across the border in an
unaccountable way complete with uh
potential for Terror groups to set up
sabotage cells throughout the country I
I put this as uh on the same scale of
national security threat as Pearl Harbor
and 911 the difference is those were
kinetic events this is more subterfuge
to set up cells to undermine us this
will limit our ability in the future to
respond if Taiwan is attacked May limit
our ability to respond and support
Israel so so I think I think your
request is valid I believe I'm going to
support it but I don't know that uh
we're completely expressing the danger
that's been uh imposed on the nation by
failing to secure our border
representative Edwards um you're
absolutely right to try to summarize the
tragedy that is happening there and a
few short minutes in a discussion here
is I think to your point is almost
impossible it is the number one national
security issue facing this country
unquestionably whether you're looking at
uh terrorism cells uh you know uh not to
move this to the northern border and
Southern border issue but the fact that
we have had hundreds and hundreds of of
apprehensions of individuals on the
terrorist watch list illegally trying to
illegally cross these borders um is it's
very real um so then you add the the
drugs and you had the trafficking when I
when you stand there and look across
that River you can literally see the
cartels like they're not off in the
distance they're like 100 ft away
looking right back at you and their blue
tent cities uh effectively holding
people hostage in those tent cities till
they can extort the funds out of them to
cross migrants are not allowed to cross
unless they pay off the cartels and
they're Crossing in thousands so now you
have the entire Southern border
effectively on the on the Mexico side at
least being controlled by multi-billion
Dollar Enterprises of some of the most
ruthless individuals on the planet
cartels that can be paid off for to do
anything so this is an immense uh issue
the the thing that stings me we talk a
lot about the fentanyl obviously and
that's really my number one uh Focus
here and I think the mission uh how it
affects new hampter family so darly but
uh again standing on that border um you
could write novels about what you see
with the the results of the human
trafficking the sexual trafficking the
trafficking of children um yeah I'll
tell you a little just one thing that
really got me you know if you're under
13 years old when you are first if you
are apprehended and you come across
illegally by border patrol you don't get
marked down you don't get recorded So
what happens they then traffic that
child and and if you have two in two
adults with you they are considered your
quote parents so they walk free so then
they take that child they being the
cartels traffic them back to the
southern border and use them effectively
as a mule to get freedom for two more
individuals and they do it again and
again and the board of Patrol has said
I've seen the same child a dozen times
and there's nothing I can do about it
I'm not allowed to enforce the laws I'm
not allowed to enforce the policies of
this country I've been told not to
border patrol Southern border patrol is
as frustrated as anyone and uh
especially again we're focusing on Eagle
Pass the main reason we're focusing on
Eagle passes I think as a lot of folks
know not just a couple hundred but
thousands of folks were coming across a
day the efforts that Governor Abbott put
into place really straining his own
resources have had Direct results they
reduce it from thousand a day to like 10
to 15 a day or even less I think in a
few days it's it's like under five so
you can this isn't just window dressing
these are getting real results and by
having New Hampshire and other states
step up they can now expand uh the
operations that have have yielded
results again not just for Texas but for
the entire
country second question follow
up uh thank thank you for your response
um so so this is a different type of
question I had a um an old broken down
he wouldn't mind me describing him that
way an old broken down retired sarden
major uh reach out to me who uh was uh
part of our efforts during the Vietnam
war to use National Guardsmen to provide
Riot security and uh so the question he
asked me was will our Guardsmen U be
protected from uh criminal immunity for
their official Act act what what was
required uh during the Vietnam war to
protect National Guardsmen because they
aren't protected like law enforcement
are from Criminal immunity from
prosecution uh is that they had to be uh
deputized locally so that they would get
that immunity shield and I know I'm
getting into some old history in detail
but I'm I'm just concerned that given
that the migrants can initiate contact
with our soldiers even though that's not
intended to be part of their mission I I
just want to make sure that if they do
end up in some kind of um engagement
that's been incited by others that that
they are not subject to Federal Criminal
prosecution uh the answer to there is no
uh and and the reason is a couple F
number one they are going to be
following the letter of the law they
will not be breaking the law um as the
text military is doing as the Texas
department of safety is doing and they
the um Texas National Guard effectively
the Tex we've called the Texas
department of military I believe uh will
have operational control of these
individuals as they follow the law these
law I I I I may I may not have made my
concern clear I'm not worried about our
soldiers violating the law I'm worried
about wanting abuse of federal profit
prosecutory authority to if there is any
sort of contact to criminalize our
Guardsmen because of animosity to us
stepping up and doing the mission sure
so I I want to protect our soldiers from
Criminal prosecution to the extent that
there's a legal way to do it sure I look
I technically I would probably defer to
the attorney general for the for the
technical uh uh legalities there I would
say this um we sent Guardsmen um men and
women of the National Guard to
California in 2021 we sent almost 200 of
them to mckel and Texas uh for almost a
Year's deployment just last year um th
those issues have never have never risen
uh which is again I believe the
protections are there thank
you represent Lehman for a question
followed by Senator gray thank you Mr
chairman uh thanks for being here
Governor so there have been I I believe
two requests in the past uh which were
funded by federal money this request of
course is general fund ons the $850,000
as someone that lost their son to
fentanyl fentanyl overdose I'm acutely
aware of what's going on at the southern
border and with the drugs coming in from
as far away as India now China coming to
our West Coast some of the highest
amounts of fentanyl are pouring through
the border of California and Arizona
right now and a lot of that's being done
by American
citizens so my question to you you it
would seem to me that this $850,000
would be more appropriately spent with
drug and
alcohol uh prevention here in New
Hampshire or enforcement versus sending
15 Guardsmen down to Texas which to me
you know 15 Guardsmen I don't see them
doing you know not no disrespect to the
guard but 15 what kind of a difference
is that going to make on this thousands
of miles of Border where people are just
flowing across and being unchecked where
that 200 the $850,000 would be probably
better spent here in New Hampshire since
it is General funds and if your request
was or our request before us was federal
funds I don't think you'd have any
opposition but this general fund dollars
and as you indicated in your address uh
yesterday we've got to be pretty Frugal
and mindful of our spending so I just
hope you can respond to that sure um
look I we we spent a lot of money tens
of millions of dollars on drug
introdiction here recovery treatment
programs uh we've put record numbers of
of dollars into those programs and by
all means if somebody wants to add some
more dollars into additional
interdiction efforts specifically around
our met teams and the department of
safety I'm all for that that would be
great but again um just because you're
focusing on efforts here uh the there is
a direct result of what's Happening Here
from the southern border there's no
question there is a complete lack of
effort on the department of the federal
government who has the roles and
responsibilities to enforce the laws on
the border to limit drug smuggling drug
trafficking but they're willingly not
doing it so the states are stepping up
so again you can't of course we have to
put all the efforts we can here at home
but if no one is going to mine that
southern border then the states are
going to step up and do it not one state
or two states but a partnership
hopefully of all 50 we'll see what
happens but uh in Partnership and to the
to the idea that well this is 15
individuals yeah look when I spoke with
Governor Abbott he'd love to see three
or four thousand people down on the
southern border well we have about one 1
250th of the US population so if every
state did stepped up and did what we're
doing yeah you'd end up with three or
4,000 people on the border we're doing
our part we're putting that that those
15 skilled individuals are exactly what
they're looking for exactly what they
need and the timeline that the folks on
the front line are looking for they're
looking for 60 to 90 days of assistance
so um no we're we're meeting the exact
needs as is being requested um and I I
think your point is very well taken we
can always have more efforts here on in
New Hampshire we um we have opportunity
we have funds to do this um and again
the southern border is a huge part of
the problem here in New Hampshire
there's no question about
that thank you thank you Mr chairman
Senator gray for a question well it's as
much a statement as a question because
uh uh as soon as I was informed of this
uh by the Senate President that this was
going to come before us the first words
out of my mouth to the Senate President
was the northern border okay and let me
explain why okay that we have
individuals in this state who have
fought against finding out if we have a
problem at the the northern border and
how big that problem is those same
individuals have said that's why we
shouldn't spend any money on this that
or the other thing so the more I can get
individuals who understand the problem
and get training of what's
happening the better off New Hampshire
is we have States like New York and New
York City who now say they're full all
right that has gotten the atttention of
the president and Congress and now we
are going to in my opinion be more and
more Vigilant about people coming across
that southern border which is going to
put additional pressure on States like
New Hampshire where we have the northern
border and that is why I support this
those IND individuals who are would be
coming back after this deployment are
going to have information that I believe
is going to be very valuable to the
state as we secure the southern border
and those individuals who are trying to
come across move to the northern border
and I'd let you comment if you'd care to
I no I I I agree wholeheartedly I mean
we've obviously and thanks to the
legislature and the efforts here uh
we've put a lot of effort on the
northern border you know the uh northern
border Alliance and that we've that
we've put together and again when we
talk about the northern border just to
be clear um you know we talking about
Maine uh New Hampshire Vermont into just
the eastern part we call the Swanton
sector the eastern part of New York um
some of the bigger issues we don't see
as much fentanyl we have see some coming
across the northern border to be sure um
the bigger issues on the northern border
for me revolve around the folks on the
terrorism watch list we have a lot of
folks on the terrorism watch list
specifically uh in the Buffalo and in
the swaton sector they come down uh out
of Montreal uh mostly uh but the the
issue at hand for for me and today and
for has been in the state for you know
over a decade now two decades almost uh
is the spanyol crisis and we know that
the vast majority almost all of it comes
up from that southern border and again
it's amazing that you know be you can
actually follow they can follow it so
closely it comes from the southern
border into Texas to New York and
Providence I'm not knocking on New York
and Providence these are just kind of
the the way it comes up into Northern
Massachusetts and then they use that as
uh as kind of a direct Highway into the
three Northern the New England State so
you can follow the bouncing ball it it's
not a hypothetical it's not supposition
you can see exactly what is coming from
the southern border and trace it right
up into um you know virtually every city
and town in in New Hampshire without a
doubt so um no it's very real it's
impactful and it's affecting families
today thank
you senator dallesandro for a question
uh thank you thank you Mr shman Governor
thank you for coming it's always always
good to see you uh Governor uh as as you
know in hille 2 we we appropriated 1.5
billion for the northern border and uh
that's where we thought the concern was
for for New Hampshire and we we funded
that with general fund money so it it it
seems it seems to be we have done more
than our part in addressing this
situation the Congress of the United
States particularly the Republican
controlled House of Representatives has
refused to to accept a plan to deal with
the southern border situation and we've
got about 20,000 people at the southern
border right now between uh our border
patrol and and other entities it it it
seems to be that spending 800,000 of
general fund monies and sending 15
people although it's a wonderful thought
of of yours in terms of support it seems
to be the real issue is the Congress
funding what they should be funding to
protect the the the southern border our
15 guys AR going to make a great deal of
difference but
indeed your ability as a as
a high-ranking public official and a
member of the Republican party I think
that effort should be spent getting the
republicans in Congress to come up with
the money that's that's that's there to
to to do what we should be doing and uh
and and certainly the fentanyl crisis is
problematic but as said by my colleague
uh representative leechman much of that
money much of that fentol is being
brought in by
Americans and it's a terrible terrible
situation and we deal with it here uh
our overdose debts in the city of
Manchester and the City of nashille have
been severe so it it it seems to be the
pressure should be should be uh really
really applied to the Republican members
of the Congress to fund border security
uh that's that to me is a great way to
spend our our money I could think of a
couple of times government where with
the National Guard was brought brought
up and to to take care of things and one
was way way back uh just actually when
your father and I were colleagues in the
House of
Representatives when buddies had to be
spent by uh by that general fund money
because of the sebr situation because of
the the thousands of people that will
put in National Guard armories and so
forth and so on that was I think a
worthy use of of general fund Monies to
protect the people of the State of New
Hampshire and and it it seems to me what
we' have done to the northern border boy
it it it makes a great deal of sense and
we're succeeding I I'm not sure that
800,000 when there are so many needs if
you looked at the number of of requests
for more money that are before the
Senate finance committee as we speak
would' say uh how can we spend this
money better for the people of the State
of New Hampshire and I and I appreciate
the sentiment but I I I think we have to
look at that would you address that sir
yeah absolutely so let's first talk
about Washington DC the bill that is not
look like it's not going to pass in
Congress is a complete political red
herring the fact is that within the
first 100 days of office Joe Biden
signed 16 different executive orders
proclamations uh and policy memos that
rescinded uh the remain in Mexico policy
that reins stilled The Catch and Release
policy that completely handcuffed the
ability of border patrol to do their
jobs policy drastically changed that has
nothing to do with this bill the idea
that this bill is somehow a solution to
a problem that was created 3 years ago
on January 20th 2021
um is is um a fallacy and and it's all
that that's simply all politics you
bring up 20,000 people that are already
on the border down there that's right
and they're not allowed to do their jobs
they're not allowed to patrol the way
they're they're designed to patrol the
laws are very clear that say that um
that border patrol shall detain the laws
are very clear that says that a legal
entry is a federal crime the laws are
very clear that says that the uh border
patrol has a requirement to maintain
operation control through border
barriers and other means necessary so
all those laws are in place all those
policies were rescinded by Joe Biden
nothing to do with the bill there's
funds there there's opportunity there
it's more of a policy crisis than
anything so by having what the the
governor of Texas has done is said okay
they he's actually removed border patrol
from that area said we're simply going
to not enforce random laws we're just
going to enforce the laws on our books
and on the federal books in conjunction
with what is already there um because
they won't now that requires funds state
of Texas has put up over $2 billion of
their own money $2 billion just to
Simply enforce laws that the federal
government uh has told their own team
not not to enforce um so that's I I just
caution folks to think that somehow if
this bill passed everything would
magically be fix of course that's not
true um they did not need this bill to
do their
jobs yeah thank you thank thank you
Governor I I just have one other comment
the governor of Texas put razor wires
razor wire out and put boys in the water
to uh deter people crossing the border
uh many people have have died there
there are few people that have drowned
because of this and that's that's kind
of inum made uh let's they got 20,000
people let them let them do their job
and and indeed it can be done if the
Republican L Congress of the United
States were to pass the legislation
that's before them that was passed in
the senate in a bipartisan vote uh we
we've got to do things in a bipartisan
manner in order to make things happen
you've articulated that on many
occasions and I and I think the response
would be very positive to to a
bipartisan approach and I would hope
that you would you would use everything
in your power to make that happen so if
I may address that in 2022 there were
159 drownings along the Texas border uh
because folks were incentivized there
was no barrier they were incentivized to
try to risk their lives to come across
in the river since that razor wire has
been put up there's no longer an
incentive they know there's not a path
for them to come that has been reduced
by a third there were only 55 drownings
ac across that Texas border in 2023 so
by having no barriers by having these
open incentives people are going to the
extremes risking their lives thinking
they're just crossing a river and they
end up drowning it's incredibly
dangerous it is not a razor wire issue
that is causing the drownings if
anything those barriers have reduced
67% Senator representative wner for a
question thank you chairman Wier and um
Mr Governor this is the fiscal committee
and I do have your letter and your
request but usually we're these uh
requests that come before us are backed
up with details about how the money will
be spent and I wondered if you can
provide us with a detailed uh summary of
how these how this $850,000 will be
spent sure so this uh those funds uh
that estimate is being is provided by
obviously the the National Guard so I
defer if you I'll give as many details
as I can but I would also obviously
defer you to the um Adent General and
the deputy
General hey Warren how are you um for
additional details but my uh that those
numbers were created and based on a
90-day deployment for 15 individuals
including the cost of housing um uh
daily wages um some minor equipment
costs travel uh things of that nature um
yeah sure come on up or if there's other
other things in there and I would only
add that you know when we when I looked
at the estimated cost from the National
Guard and then compared to other costs
for other deployments uh everything
seemed to be at least in line with with
um you know what those expenses would
be for the record Warren Perry Deputy
agent General New Hampshire Department
of military Affairs and bment Services I
just want to make sure that I understood
the question uh representative you're
asking about how the how the $850,000
uh amount was arrived at yes so we a
detailed a a detailed summary of it that
we could have for the committee I I I
will I will get a no kidden detailed
summary I won't be able to speak
necessarily extemporaneously over it
people are we generally assess the cost
at about $600 a day per Soldier to go we
we estimated about
$650,000 just in salary and benefit so
that includes lodging meals uh pum uh
those those kinds of things that just
are General living expenses they don't
get the same pay that they would get if
they were federalized it's a little bit
less But it includes basic allowing for
housing basic allowance for subsistance
a pum for meals uh a $5 uh a day for
incidentals meal uh incidentals so about
about that
$650,000 just in wages for 90 days and
then travel and other other Associated
costs associated with the equipment
moving things down but we'll get we can
get a detailed accounting of that of
that amount I think we would appreciate
that thank you
yes thank
you representative Rosen mul for a
question Senator thank you Mr chairman
and thank you governor for being with us
this morning I think we should note that
the Border
Patrol
Endor the bipartisan Senate deal that
the US House torpedoed but what I wanted
to say is that in Senate Finance we're
all really careful with money and we're
sitting on some
important appropriation bills because
one we're
uncertain in the middle of the budget
how revenues are going to hold up and
two we think we're facing potentially
some big expenditures that might come at
us these bills
include money to fight
cyanobacteria from president Bradley
which is not only threatening the health
of our Lakes but leading to an alarming
rise in ALS cases and another bill that
would appropriate money to remediate
lead paint dust which is poisoning
hundreds of New Hampshire children every
year and I wonder if you would agree
with me that bills like these these two
efforts would have a more direct and
positive impact on the health and
well-being of granite Staters than
sending this this National Guard unit
down to Texas thank you I got to tell
you I love seeing being the Democrats so
fiscally disciplined it's wonderful I
love I love the sentiment
um the the two comments I'll I'll put
their cater and and I appreciate the
comments very much um look we've created
a lot of opportunity in the state
economically we have great surpluses we
have a lot of financial opportunity and
I would challenge that there is no
bigger Health crisis in the state right
now than losing four to 500 people a
year every year for the past 10 years um
it doesn't just it's not just I mean
those loss of lives are devastating it
devastates families it Bank it bankrupts
families with what you're you add into
the individuals that aren't maybe not
haven't died from it but have been
addicted for years um have had all the
uh subsequent illnesses that come from
that so if you ask me the fentanyl
crisis is the number one crisis uh that
the state has faced in terms of health
uh in in quite a long time we've put a
lot of money and a lot of effort to it
um this is less than a million dollars
to do something that should have been
done by somebody else but they're
unwilling to do it Joe Biden is
unwilling to do it and not only is he
unwilling to do it he's actually
proactively told his teams to not follow
law to not do what they're supposed to
do um so again I I think this is a a
terrific expenditure of $850,000 to be
part of a national effort to finally
stop uh and and have a a stronger effort
to slow down the fentanyl that is
completely unmitigated in terms of
coming into this country for that 450
million doses that was um of fentanyl
that was obtained by Texas um imagine
the hundreds of millions of doses of
fentanyl came in that they didn't get
right that's just what they got um and
given that you have we've seen it all on
TV folks coming in by the thousands a
day thousands and thousands and
thousands in each of these entryways a
day and when you know that the smuggling
and the and that what the cartels are
doing this is a multi-billion dollar
operation uh on the other side of the
border to drive this um and look I and I
have to go back a little bit while I
respect some of the comments that were
made here that there are Americans
involved in drug trafficking make no
mistake this is driven by Mexican drug
cartels the most Ruth ruthless
individuals on the planet um these are
murderers these are sex traffickers
these are human traffickers these are
drug dealers that are praying on the
opportunity that Joe Biden has handed
them with an open border so if we can be
part of that 50-state effort I
absolutely think this $850,000 out of
our what's our budget per year Mr chair
7 billion plus 7 A5 billion a year that
we spend I think we can we can find the
850,000 in all the surpluses that we
keep bringing in month after month to
make a uh to be part of this National
effort to finally uh put some assistance
and help if we just sit back and say you
know what Texas thanks good job keep
going keep spending your own dollars on
the behalf of the other 49 states that
is not the solution this is a national
crisis and and uh it's a 50 at this
point it's not a federal crisis a
federal issue because they're not taking
it up so the states are going to do what
what we do best we're going to stand up
and protect our citizens so M Mr chair I
urge committee members to stay on the
subject of the discussion today are you
ready for a
motion I I have others still to to
discuss I'll come back to you uh Senator
Bradley for a question uh thank you very
much thank you very much Mr chairman
good morning Governor first of all I I
just can't Salute Your leadership enough
on this um you're using RSA
9913 which is a civil emergency
statute sorry correct if 400 deaths from
fentanyl per year since 2015 is not a
civil emergency I don't know what
is how quickly we forget that 11
terrorists
736 known or suspected terrorists have
been apprehended at the border and that
doesn't count the Goda ways we watch the
news every
night people are sleeping in Logan
Airport people are
overwhelming shelters schools you name
it hotels
because there's no other place for
them Street crime in many cities from
illegal migrants is out of control we
have seen that and then we have
seen the reaction when they get bail and
their use of gestures of what they think
of our
system if this isn't a civil emergency
nothing is a civil e emergency now would
you agree with me because there's been a
lot of discussion already this morning
about the inability of Congress to act
the house has actually passed hr2 which
is a real border security measure which
contrast to the quote unquote bipartisan
measure which allowed 500 thou 5,000
people per day 1.8 million people to
cross the border every day before
there'd be any
amount of enforcement did not
reinstitute the remain and Mexico policy
did not end Catch and Release
liberalized work permits and provided
new resources to people to um be able to
use the legal system in this country
that may have been bipartisan but it
security so I don't think you are left
with any choice whatsoever than to
work with people like Governor Abbott in
Texas to protect New Hampshire it is a
civil emergency would you agree with me
couldn't have said it better myself 100%
On Spot thank you Senator gray I move
the uh I move the item on pass second
motion and a second to adopt item FIS
24072 is there any further discussion
from committee members there already
been 40
minutes are you ready for the question
yes should have some in here there we go
24072 representative Edwards yes ought
to pass
clerk votes yes representative
Lehman no Representative walner no
representative uh no Senator gray
yes uh Senator Bradley
yes Senator bzel yes Senator
Rosenwald Senator delandro
yes
uh Mr chairman the vote is six to four
in favor of the motion the item is
you okay moving back to the regular
agenda the first item is acceptance of
the minutes of January 19th 2024 some
move Senator gray moves to adopt
Senator Bradley seconds is there any
further discussion Corrections or
anything seeing none all in favor say I
I oppose
adopted okay we have uh 24 items on a
consent calendar which covers tabs 3
through n eight of those have been
removed on request of
members first item I will refer to
2460 and then on Tab
five
24049 under Tab
2470 any others to be
removed I'll entertain a motion to adopt
the remaining items move consent
calendar Senator gray moves second by
Senator Bradley to adopt the remaining
items further discussion seeing none all
in favor say I I oppose no the remaining
items are adopted we'll move first to
2460 who had the question on that
Senator Senator rosenal and
representative
Earth thank you Mr
this is not okay good morning Kim McKay
commod of the New Hampshire Veterans
Home good morning Janine norwitz new
chair of veterans home welcome to
finance a
fiscal fiscal we'll get it right
Finance um thank you thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
yesterday we got information from the
veterans home that
what you have an overall Staffing
vacancy rate of 35% and a nursing
44% um my question is what specific
efforts are you undertaking to fill
those jobs particularly the nursing 61
thank you for that question so we have
been um recruiting heavily with uh any
means possible so we go to colleges
we're going to be at one of the college
campuses uh that specializes in nursing
education so we're doing job fairs at
colleges we're in the newspapers we're
doing as many press release articles as
we can uh this week we were on the front
of two papers which was wonderful uh
highlighting our LNA program our
licensed nursing assistant program which
we created and have had some great
success with creating nursing position
uh and to nursing positions through the
licensed nursing program and we continue
to
um we are supported by the governor in
the 10% raise that helped us because
those nursing fees or their nursing um
salaries were and um helped with
enhancements and the enhancements were
uh tough to always um recruit nurses in
because they knew we had to go every two
years so those enhancements when they
became part of their regular salary has
helped us and we are seeing a decline we
were up in the 48% for nurses and so
that's starting to go down which has
been helpful for us so we're going to
continue on the same path and try to
recruit we're trying to uh let people
know that when they're graduating from
nursing school you don't have to go to
the ERS you don't have to go into the
med surge you can come to long-term care
um and so we're going to continue that
that those
efforts thank you thank you thank you so
you have a 44% nursing vacancy rate but
you don't have a
44% bed
census um are patients getting less
residents getting Less
Direct
Care from nursing staff because of your
high vacancy rates no we actually are
holding a 44% vacancy rate for the
resident beds as well as well so we we
are only holding right now 127 residents
I have five more pending uh five more
veterans will be coming in the next
couple of weeks we have capped our
census at 137 because we need to provide
the quality of care that they uh deserve
and they expect um and we want to make
sure our nursing Staff feel comfortable
with the care they're providing so we
have not filled all of our beds and all
of our vacancies with the vet because we
can't do that until we have a a larger
them any further questions from
committee members will entertain a
motion to adopt the
item
thank motion by Senator dallis Sandro
second by Senator gray to adopt item
24060 any further discussion are you
ready for the question all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is adopted thank
you moving on to tab
recognized
don't keep the red light
closer good morning Amy Newbury director
of administration with the Department of
Safety uh Jeffrey Phillips I'm the
assistant director at the division of
fire stands training and Emergency
Medical
Services welcome to fiscal committee
representative Earth is recognized thank
you for taking my questions and I
apologize if they're somewhat repetitive
because I did try to ask these questions
um this note makes reference
to mobile integrated healthc care and at
first that made me think of our mobile
crisis units that DHHS uh supports and I
understand this is not that I'm assuming
it means ambulances since we're talking
about the EMS here um and it also talks
about initiatives development
implemented by local Fire EMS a local
Fire EMS agencies assisting patients in
taking care of themselves in their own
homes I'm just wondering if you could
tell me a little bit more about what
this is outside of
what the normal EMT function is um in a
community uh yes uh thank you for the
question um so mobile Integrated Health
has been in New Hampshire for uh a
little while um we used this initial
Grant um to fund uh my full-time
position and some other trainings to
train the local uh fire and EMS agencies
that that provide EMS so it's a function
of EMS but it's on more of the
prevention side it's proactively going
out to their communities depending on
what programs they want to develop in
regards to um whe whether it's a Falls
program or it it's an education program
so it's proactive rather than being
called to an emergency incident it's the
firing EMS people that provide uh em uh
EMS Services they're going out to their
Community speaking with individuals um
it could be they just got discharged by
the hospital so they're going to do a
house call to explain what their
medications are to make sure they're
doing medications while they're doing it
that they may do it like a home survey
um to remove any trip hazards um so
there's multiple different um programs
that communities can come out with um
what we've tried to do at the state is
build that framework and provide this
training um to the locals so they can
build these programs within their
communities um and the goal of these
programs is to reduce these individuals
either having to call an an ambulance in
the middle of the night to go to the
emergency room because they didn't do
their prescriptions correctly um so it's
really a proactive report uh a proactive
approach um to provide Health Care um
and provide a mechanism with the trained
Personnel um to to deal with these
individuals that may not fully
understand what medications they need or
or something to that
effect follow up thank you that that
helps quite a bit so I'm from where
small town would I expect to see this in
my community or is this more targeted
like Manchester nashille the the cities
uh it's for any Community um it's a it's
resources they need the resources um I
mean we have larger communities that
have it we have smaller communities to
have it and it really depends on what
the community chooses to do um it could
be a uh it could be like just going into
somebody's house and helping them do a
televisit with their primary care or
checking so it's really up to the local
um what we do at the state is there's
requirements and protocols that they
have to follow to make sure that
everything's being done part of this
funding is actually to to supply um
software to the locals at no cost to
them to be able to because they have to
provide patient care documentation that
this is what they did um so it really
it's up to the community specific
there's no requirement um but it does
fall within the em
explanation representative Edwards for a
question uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I I I I
really don't have a well-formed question
about this I just uh have a discomfort
that's come up as I've I've listened to
this this is a the the government doing
proactive Health and Welfare checks on
our
citizens and uh so this brings up issues
of of of um of of of consent and of
appropriateness and reimbursement and
all and all of that and I I just would
like to know uh what kind of review
process has there been to to really take
a look at uh how we're identifying
potential I'm going to call them
patients clients whatever the right term
is how how we how we're making sure that
we're really getting the right people
and that we're not overreaching
um or under reaching how how is there is
there a review process to make sure we
got this just
right um I'm
sorry um so there's a review process in
the program uh to make sure it meets all
the requirements as part of the review
process um the EMS agency uh contacts
the like the home healthcare area um
because it's somewhat overlaps with that
um as I said it was proactive it's not
necessarily proactive where EMS agencies
are going to like cold calling knocking
people it's really a referral process um
from their PCP um so if they uh if they
really their Community is the one that
is kind of advertising that they have
this service um but there no one's
required to do it um they're not um
they're not like like I said coold
calling people knocking on people's
doors um it's really it could be is we
go to an EMS incident and it's the third
time that we've gone to this individual
this week we provide them with
information about the program um but
it's it's really it's it's up to the
patient um to whether they want the
services or not
questions okay uh representative F moves
to adopt
24061 Senator dandro second is there any
further discussion from the committee
seeing none you ready for the question
all in favor say I I oppose no the item
moving on to tab six and
question good morning uh for the record
John fella attorney general and I'm
joined by Kathy Carr our director of
administration welcome to fiscal thank
you uh thank you Mr attorney general
take my question um so this one kind of
ties into the ones I've been asking one
pre previously asked this talks about
coordinating Statewide crisis inter
intervention and Behavioral Health
initiatives and as I'm sure you're well
aware the DH HHS has this mobile baby
Health crisis intervention thing and I
understand that these are not related um
and it talks about establishing a
Statewide treatment coordinator and
they'll help standardize treatment
courts could you just explain what what
these are and and how may may or may not
interact with other things we have in
the state related to uh Behavioral
Health crisis absolutely thank you for
the question representative so this this
is a Federal grant that is really
focused on on Behavioral Health but but
Behavioral Health in the criminal
justice system and in law enforcement so
this uh this is a skip Grant so the
state Crisis Intervention uh program and
it's it's an interesting Grant it's a
good opportunity for the state it it
will provide the state on an ongoing
basis a little over $650,000 a year um
to do these types of things but this
particular Grant required a lot of
vetting under this grant we had to set
up a crisis intervention Advisory board
with stakeholders that board had to
include law enforcement uh community
members representatives from the courts
prosecutors and Behavioral Health
Providers victim Services professionals
and and legal counsel so we set up a
board that represented all these
stakeholders we had a couple of County
attorneys on the board we had Susan
Sterns the head of Nami on the board we
had Maggie Pritchard who's the executive
director of The Lakes Region Mental
Health Center on the board um Diane
Martin administr uh director of the
administrative office of the courts so
we we had a wide range of stakeholders
on this Advisory Board and we had we
vetted ideas for spending this money
through that board we had to do that and
then submit a request to the federal
government before we could even draw
down these funds before we could even
come to fiscal for approval to draw down
these funds so I just think that's
that's important background but there's
a couple of things we're proposing to do
with this money the first as as you
noted is to establish a a uh Behavior
Health initiatives um a crisis
intervention and behavior health
initiatives coordinator position within
the Department of Justice
there's a lot of good work going on in
law enforcement right now with regard to
Crisis Intervention training and and um
other work to look at how law
enforcement can respond to the Mental
Health crisis in the state historically
at the Department of Justice we have
never had any capacity for that we
currently don't have any any single
person at the Department of Justice the
chief law enforcement agency of the
state with mental health background or
or who's dedicated to doing doing work
to to think about how law enforc can
respond to the Mental Health crisis so
the vision for this position is to help
us think about how uh or develop
strategies and and develop initiatives
from the Department of Justice to assist
law enforcement Statewide with
responding to the Mental Health crisis
uh this position
will lias with law enforcement agencies
across the state uh both state local and
County to figure out what they're doing
with regard to training try to gather
some data on who's doing what to try to
get everybody Co coordinated and on the
same page as to what the best strategies
are it will help us get a sense of who
who's doing well with training who is
who is able to provide their officers
with training who isn't will help us
look at what resources the state is
putting towards this and and where the
gaps are I think it'll be really helpful
it'll just it it will it is I see it as
the beginning of building some capacity
within the Department of Justice to
think about how law enforcement can
respond to the mental Mental Health
crisis the second position a state
treatment courts coordinator
the judicial branch right now you know
for years has has been piloting a drug
court which has been very successful in
a lot of counties they're looking to
further develop mental health courts and
they I think they have the same need
they have a need for for someone who can
help coordinate all of those efforts I
think this is a really good use of funds
and these are really good positions to
have because they help us think from the
ground up how we're going to build out
these capacities sometimes I you know
sometimes in government you see grant
money come in and you think oh we just
want to spend a lot of money on on XYZ
but we don't have somebody really
thinking about how we're going to build
out that strategy so I think starting
with these types of positions in the
judicial branch and the Department of
Justice to help us build out a strategy
is a good initial use of these funds so
sorry that was a long answer but there's
a lot of background to this grant that I
thought I should give you thank you very
much I appreciate all the background and
the thorough answer
thanks further questions from committee
members move the item a motion by
representative Ur second by Senator
Bradley to move the item I have one more
question when I read uh Statewide
treatment
Court what is included other than mental
health court and Drug Court does it also
include veterans court what courts are
included in treatment courts so Diane
Martin the director of the
administrative office of the courts is
here so I don't I'll let her speak to
that if she thinks i' leave any holes in
my answer but yes it does include drug
court um mental health courts there
we've discussed this concept of of uh uh
with with some counties at least County
attorney offices about whether the court
should should um develop some
Specialties and and uh and um perhaps a
special court for for youth who are
Justice involved there certainly
veterans courts are something that that
exists and that I think the courts
longterm would would perh s like to
build out so it includes I think it
includes all of that because all you
know those are all different categories
of individuals who may need special
treatment within the court system thank
you I don't need to wait for some other
one to answer it I have a motion in a
second is there any further discussion
from committee members all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is adopted thank
you very much thank you thank
you okay moving on to Tab
8 item FIS
Jasper good morning Mr chairman members
of the
committee and with me I have Joshua
Marshall who is the director of
Agriculture Agricultural Development
excuse
me was this uh represent representative
rosenal for a question thank you and
Senator rosenal it's not really about
the Department of Agriculture but this
was the
first item of arpa fund accept and
expend we've
been trying to get information for over
over a year now
on what amounts of ARA funds have been
appropriated but won't be spent and
therefore are
available for reallocation and you just
happen to come up first but we did get
this wonderful chart in twoo font
yesterday I think from be from
gopher that
indicates that they there's 30 I think
38.7
million that can be moved around and
today we're being asked to spend 32
million of that leaving I think
5.7
million that is still available but I
why is this not a request from goer but
a request from
agriculture are you getting this money
directly from the federal government or
is it still coming from gopher it my
understanding is still coming from
gopher as you may know there was a um a
Senate bill that would have appropriated
this amount but we've been in
discussions all along I have been you
know bugging if you will uh commissioner
Caswell for a very long time about if
there was a reallocation would there be
availability for for agriculture
ultimately that's come to fruition my
understanding is currently the bill with
the 8 million of General funds has been
put on hold um and so we were told that
yes this would be an agricultural
agriculture request from from from
gopher but this was a a collaboration if
you will all the way through the process
with the commissioner with the
governor's
office could I ask a question commiss
Caswell uh d uh director Caswell since
there going to be many items here if you
want you can take one of the seats at
the end of the table over there and use
that microphone because you'll probably
have to chime in on many of these other
items thank you Mr chair
good morning commissioner my
understanding is that we have until this
fall to do any
reallocations and this this chart is
fantastic how often will we be getting
updates so that if the
legislature wanted to whisper into the
ears of the executive branch we'd have
the opportunity
and the knowledge of what might be
available yes thanks Senator and again
Taylor Caswell uh here as the executive
director of gopher um this document I
apologize for the font size we'll we'll
we'll we'll update that in future
versions in the email we can yes ma'am
um so this uh group of reallocations all
emanate from programs that were approved
for gopher to administer so the lists
that you have here are not from other
agencies at this point they are all
exclusively programs that were under the
control of gopher to administer his
programs so we were able to be the first
to go through our own programs and make
the determination as to which of those
funds uh are no longer going to be used
or they've been closed out and they've
been otherwise written down so at this
point that we had roughly as you say
about 34 $35 million worth of funds in
that program we also have a long list of
requests from agencies um uh
commissioner Jasper being included there
for programs such as this or for
programs that are um running over in
cost so several of these as you know
were approved um now probably two years
ago and some of those are capital costs
that have seen increases in cost so
we've been trying to address those as
the priority um and so as we move
forward
um it is difficult for me to say right
now spec and I know you've heard me say
this before but specifically how much
money is going to come back because it
really depends on the ability for
agencies to spend um at a burn rate that
gets them uh within the obligation
deadline of the end of this calendar
year um I would add as we spoke about
earlier this week too is um in almost
all cases uh funds that have been um
approved by fiscal committee have
spending Authority only out till June
30th of this calendar year so that gives
us an opportunity at that point to
really see exactly which of these
programs are going to have funds that
we're going to need to get re obligated
prior to the federal deadline of the end
of the
year further question well that timing
is
unfortunate because our legislative work
is going to be done by
June of this fiscal year so are you
going to be updating this chart every
month I believe that there are some
additional um um requests that will come
for the March fiscal and if those
involve funding pools that are outside
of this then absolutely those will be
provided uh much earlier I would say
than we were able to give it to you
earlier this week for the next round of
funds but it will not be a I do not
expect it to be anywhere near the total
of this amount one vyl if I one final
so when you come before us with these
requests we're given the chance to say
yes or no there's no opportunity because
we can't add items to the fiscal agenda
to say here's what the legislature not
just the 10 of us
but the entire legislature thinks might
be appropriate uses of those funds and
so it's a source of frustration for some
of us who think that the spending
decision should be made by more than
just 10 people and that's why we keep
asking for this great information and
hope it will come before the next fisal
meeting absolutely ma'am yes we will we
will absolutely um um U be providing
that information as we go ahead thank
you thank you Mr chairman sen lean for a
question thank you Mr chairman
representative
Le I I'll take the senator at least for
the question but anyway thank you Mr
chairman and nice to see you
commissioner so I see uh there's a like
a $15 million total loss and you're only
going to be looking at getting 8 million
I'm just curious are you going to put in
request for the other seven from General
funds or federal funds or no sir thank
you thank you for the question so our
intent was never to make everybody whole
the intent was to keep people from going
out of business now that $15 million
loss is an estimate because that was
based on a
survey and so we don't really know what
will we'll have for total reported
losses we expect that it will be higher
than that but because of some of the
eligibility th the numbers are going to
change so I can tell you what our our
plan is now because the important thing
is to get money out to those who had
extreme losses to allow them to be able
to to buy seed and fertilizer Etc and
because everybody's a little different
on when they have their profit and loss
statements their schedule FS Federal
income tax right now we're on schedule
to to open this up in April 1st and
every week we will be evaluating what
comes in so our intent at the current
plan is so if somebody comes in and
they're requesting
$100,000 we will award them immediately
$50,000 we'll keep this open probably
till about June
1st and at that time we will close out
the program we will true up the numbers
so this allows at giving out 50 m uh 50%
of the
request um which is we're really only
looking to do 50% to begin with that
allows us for a total Statewide loss of
32 million which we do not believe will
happen but that way we would not over
reward anyone and we'd be we expect
everyone would get additional funds
there but in in the farming business the
importance is really going to be getting
that money out in the spring so we're
going to be ready to go when we get
through Governor Council assuming that
this is approved uh today meeting with
the advisory committee before the end of
the month to run this by them we're
working with other stakeholders to make
sure that we're not missing anything in
the application process and we're
working very closely with u UNH
Cooperative Extension with their their
experts in economics and in farming to
make sure that we're getting all of this
stuff right and we want to get this
money out the door as soon as possible
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman I'll move the item if there are
any other questions second motion by
representative lean second by Senator
gray to adopt item
2438 are you ready for the question all
in favor say I I oppose no the item is
you moving on to item
2439 Department of
Education
good morning for the record Frank adbl
Commissioner of
Education I had Senator Dallas Sandro
down is is wanting to question this item
does anybody know I'll go check for see
doing
sorry for the
okay
2439 sen alesandro is recognized for
question on item
24039 thank you thank you Mr ch but
apologize so was
inconvenienced uh thank you commissioner
when I looked at the the spend of the
money that we had already given only
half of the money has been
spent could you give me a clue as to why
we're giv a more money when they haven't
spent the money we gave them yeah so the
initial project was scheduled it's a
construction project which obviously uh
takes some amount of time the project is
scheduled to last through June of 2025
um they're actually spending a ahead of
probably the anticipated rate in terms
of how they would um progress and
they're making substantive progress on
the uh the progress or the the buildout
um I have visited there twice and walked
through the program to make sure that
they're making the progress so I think
they're actually in good shape okay but
they do have three billion of the six
billion left they do but it I mean and
it's actually about a $15 million total
project that they're working on so
there's quite a lot of work to be done
there further question further question
what is going on at the facility as we
speak the old crunch Bel facility what
what is left of the operational the
operational situation that existed prior
to the closure and so for yeah so they
are bringing back a substantive amount
of the programming that they had um the
work that we are focused on is really
the work for New Hampshire students in
particular um our residential students
particularly focused on the autism
population um in terms of the uh the the
work that they have been doing they
prioritize the residential uh facilities
that they have for these students and
that's been kind of the main emphasis of
the work that has been going on um those
residential facilities should be open
fairly soon um today I think they have
39 students that are there 23 are
residential students and they'll be
opening that up I believe they're going
to be able to get as many as 60 students
on campus for residential placement and
up to close to a 100 of day students as
well when they get all of the
refurbishment done okay one further
question when when will they be able to
uh take care of these hundred students
that you're talking about when will this
refurbishment Etc be done and will they
need more money uh so there's no
understanding that they would be
receiving more money or that they would
need more money that they are funding
the other aspects of this project and
again the completion date is 2025 June
2025 thank you thank you Mr CH thank you
thank you further questions from the
committee on the item anything to add
director
Caswell be item second
okay Senator Bradley move Senator gray
seconds to adopt item
2439 any further discussion seeing n
you're ready for the question all in
favor say I I oppose no the item is
adopted moving on next to item
Z Senator rosenal is recognized question
thank you I didn't really have a
question so much as a comment that I
think there are a lot of nonprofits that
have lost money and I
didn't come to learn anything that would
indicate to me that this particular
one
deserves um reimbursement so I just
wanted to vote on it thank you don't
want to have any questions no thank you
any me member of the committee have any
question I don't have a question but if
I could speak to it Senator so I think
if you look back at
um many of the items that we have funded
over the course of this process an awful
lot of nonprofits have been
funded the Highland Games um in
Lincoln had to abide by the new protocol
in terms of tent policy based on what
happened in Lancaster where people were
killed and they used all du
caution um to cancel part of the 2023
games um it was actually a wise decision
as the winds were um what was expected
the tents lifted up there were no people
there so there was no one hurt but when
the tents collapsed uh the poles were
bent and it would have been a problem
had people been there so my
understanding is the games bring in
35,000 plus people um every Hotel up and
down Route 93 in the Plymouth to
Littleton area is fully booked that's a
huge amount of Revenue that comes into
the state it's a Economic Development
Revenue I'm not going to say it's like
motorcycle week but it certainly um sign
$450,000 um so this doesn't make them
whole but it certainly um similar to the
debate that we just had on agriculture
um should enable them to continue to do
what they do and the state of New
Hampshire benefits from rooms and meals
tax um to say nothing of the ancillary
spending that comes in so I think that
we have many examples of not for-profits
having been funded through the arpa
processes would be one more based on
fall entertain a motion to adopt all
right second Senator Bradley moves to
adopt Senator Grace seconds is there any
further discussion on item
244 seeing N Ready for the question all
in favor say I I oppose no the item is
is
adopted moving on to item
2441 somebody say no did anybody say no
on
that you wish to be
recorded can show a negative
vote and myself Mr
chairman two two negative votes the item
is
adopted
okay representa Le has a question on
item
24041 thank you thank you Mr chairman uh
nice to see you of course commissioner
so the item says that uh General funds
may be needed if federal funds are no
longer available could you give us an
idea what may means is that like 500,000
a million or maybe nothing at all um I'm
going to um answer that at this point
this is a study of a of uh security
measures at all the uh court system
around the state and I believe what the
lon is referring to is that the results
of that study may require funds outside
of the federal uh funds to com to to to
fulfill the the outcome of the that
security study okay thanks thank you Mr
chairman all right move the item second
Senator gray moves that we adopt item
2441 second by Senator Bradley are there
any further discussion seeing none
you're ready for the question all in
favor say I I oppos no items adopted
2470 still within Tab 8 it's the last
quite representative leean question on
thank you Mr
chairman to see you Charlie good to be
here so um a similar question that the
item also says that the federal funds
may not be available that General funds
may be requested to support the program
I just curious if you had a better
number than you know six I think this
calls about $6 million of federal funds
and
I think it's uh oh for the record I'm
Charlie Arling house I work at
administrative Services
um I think it's going to be enough money
and I think the it's a construction
project and I and we're working with the
legislature on it and and I suspect that
um it's the kind of thing where you know
if you're working with Terry on
something he doesn't want to Forstall
the opportunity to ask for more money
later so just to follow up so you you
don't plan each your hat then if this
goes over I do not okay good thanks
thank you Mr
add okay uh Senator gray moves the item
seconded by Senator Bradley Senator
Bradley further discussion on FIS 2470
seeing n you ready for the question all
in favor say I I oppose no the item is
adopted
believe we're done with the consent
calendar moving on to the regular
10 first item is
uh
Services RF for 45
million doll questions any questions
from the
committee Senator delis Sandro oh thank
you thank you Mr CH thank you thank you
very much for
coming uh it's it's an unusual situation
we've had conversation will you keep us
appraised of this situation because I I
think it it does have an effect on us as
we move forward yes uh good morning uh
chairman wer members of the committee
Nathan white Chief Financial Officer
with the Department Health and Human
Services um yes uh Senator delis Sandro
um and and for for the record Senator
delandro is referring to the transfer
that you see within accounting unit
7948 uh where we're moving uh $22
million of fund to set aside as a
reserve um to deal with a situation
where Federal Medicaid funds may not be
claimable uh for facilities that are
considered to be qrtp qual qualified
Residential Treatment um
um programs sorry I'm forgetting the
acronym there um it's come to our
attention that those could potentially
be considered imds if they are
considered imds then the federal funds
wouldn't be claimable um we are actively
investigating uh this situation we're
looking at every facility to understand
whether they are considered qrps we're
also uh reaching out to our partners in
other states because we are not the only
state in the country that is currently
dealing with this issue um we've also
been on uh the phone with members of the
delegation to DC as there is discussion
at the federal level to potentially
resolve uh this issue so it's a very to
Senator Dell Sandra's point it's a very
Dynamic situation um this is a reserve
that we're setting aside we will likely
come back in May and go ahead and move
those funds back if if we can um but we
really just want to make sure that we
had the funds
available one further question the the
material that you you gave us
I can't read it the point is so small
that even with the magnifying glass I
can't figure it out so I would I would
say that U if if indeed you need more
Mone to get the printed exped I I would
be more than happy to donate I I will
put forward a prioritize need for that
larger paper thank you thank you very
much uh just just as a comment in
support of Senator delis Sandro's
comment uh I did contact uh
the department because uh when I get an
item that says the division of children
youth and families I'm going to take
away a million but I'm going to give
them 5 million it doesn't tell me what
the cost classes are underneath it and
they are going to work with the
legislative budget office to give us the
detail that we need without that
magnifying glass and I know that the uh
director of the LBA was in my office and
did borrow my magnifying
glass to to to try and help explain this
to me so thank
you further discussion move the item
second Senator Bradley moves to
accept Senator Grace seconds seeing no
further discussion are ready for the
question to adopt 24069 all in favor say
yes or
I let's be consistent I oppose no the
item is adopted
11 Department efficient game and I see
here uh good morning um Scott Mason
executive director of New Hampshire
fishing game and with me today is Corey
Riley from our uh Marine Division and
Corey is the
um the title's not project manager but
she is the person responsible for this
project out on the Sea Coast thank you
24051 second senat dandro moves to
accept Senator gray seconds any further
discussion seeing
none all in favor say I I oppose no
thank you for coming the item is adopted
good luck with the project
fund Senator dallesandro moves the item
second by Senator Bradley to adopt
item
2453 seeing no discussion you're ready
for the question all in favor say I I
oppose no item is adopted thank
second motion by Senator Dallas Sandro
to adopt second by Senator gray is there
any further discussion seeing none you
ready for the question all in favor say
adopted
maintenance I would I would I would move
the it's a regular we've seen this a
number of times second motion to adopt
by
Senator dallesandro second by Senator
gray on item
24055 any further discussion seeing none
you're ready for the question all in
favor say I I oppose no item is adopted
14 judicial councel this is a fairly
routine thing move the item the item
second motion by Senator dallesandro
second by Senator gray to move the item
2456 any further discussion seeing none
you ready for the question all in favor
15 item
24052 Department of
Corrections any
questions okay there will be questions
thank
you welcome to fiscal you can introduce
yourselves good morning uh commissioner
Hanks forgets that she can't be here
today I'm Lisa Stone director of
administration good morning I'm Paula
Mattis director of medical and forensic
services
and Benjamin Carboni the chief of
Pharmacy for the Department of
Corrections thank you Mr chair Senator
Rosen I notice on page two in the
explanation that the long acting
injectable antis psychotic has doubled
in price from one year to the
next and um my question is have you
gotten any EX explanation from the
manufacturer of how they justify
doubling the price in one year uh at
this time no we we haven't gotten any
justification from the manufacturer on
that
use get a little closer apologies uh at
this point in time no we have not uh
gotten any justification from the
manufacturer on the pricing of the
product followup is this the 340b price
uh on that particular medication that
would not be the 340b price we have a
340b STD Grant which allows us to order
our uh hcv HIV uh and other STD related
medications through that Grant we are
looking at expanding that uh at this
point in time but at this point in time
we just order for the uh STD grant for
STD based uh
prescribing follow up please th this is
new news to me I thought we were fully
using the
340b program in the Corrections
Department thank you senator for your
comments um I will respond to that for
you we have been um researching that the
possibility of using the three Federal
340b program for all medications at this
time there are only two other uh excuse
me pardon me now three other states
doing that and we were watching and
monitoring that process process and
learning from them in fact Dr carbon has
had contact with North Dakota I believe
it is in another state to talk with them
about the specifics of the arrangements
of doing that we are looking forward to
doing that as soon as we can it is on my
agenda when I meet with commissioner
Hanks next week to so we can start
taking steps know if we can be will make
sure um she is aware of that we will
communicate to you Senator thank you
thank you Mr chairman Senator
dallesandro thank you Mr chairman we've
been concerned about the drug costs in
the in Corrections for a long period of
time it and I I think a number of
suggestions have been made about doing
things uh to reduce these cost you you
know creative ways doing
that and and the number the number of
people who are receiving medications at
the correction facilities uh seems to be
uh the severity of of the problem the
medical problem and the the amount of
money that we're spending are we still
diligently working for solutions to
cross
control the short answer Senator and
thank you for the question is yes we are
exploring and continue to explore all
kinds of creative ways to manage costs
for example we are fortunate to be part
of the uh State opioid response grant
money to cover costs for medications for
treatment of opioid use disorder that is
a significant cost savings to the state
we have a what's called in very typical
in healthcare environments Pharmacy and
Therapeutics committee also known as a
p&t committee where we meet with the
heads for the example the chief medical
officer Chief Dental officer Chief
psychiatric officer and look at
utilization um of certain medications
additionally in addition to I'm happy to
repeat as much is necessary but what we
were talking about earlier of the 340b
program we are I really believe this
close because I heard back from one of
our Representatives at the AG's office
to signing um to moving forward with a
confidential disclosure agreement so
that we can talk with another company
about further reducing our pricing on
epclusa finally one of um I think the
committee respectfully I think you all
know that a large majority of our
Healthcare staff are contracted through
the RFP process with a vendor called
Wexford we meet with them regularly in
addition to contract has a critical
performance indicator that helps manage
um if costs are expended above and
beyond inflation and 10% right 10% of
the previous pardon me the previous
quarter and so there is a a tie in a
penalty quite frankly back if their
prescribers are not following some of
what we would consider to be standard
utilization management procedures in
fact um we are in the process of looking
at Q the second quarter of this fiscal
year and we'll adjust our invoice from
them based on that so we are we are open
always looking for suggestions so but I
do want to assure you we always are
looking at ways to save money and M just
wanted to point out as the governor
pointed out Democrats are fiscally
responsible and we we're doing we're
doing we're doing we're doing our job
and we address every issue based on
based on the the the the cost and Cost
Containment thank you Mr chairman move
the
it I do have a question Mr chairman let
me get a second and then we'll go on
with further second from motion by
represent Senator gray to adopt second
by Senator delis Sandro further
discussion represent lean thank you Mr
chairman U and thanks for being here and
certainly commend the commissioner and
the staff I understand that you folks
are the best or one of the best state
run prisons in the country based on what
we heard the other day uh do you
anticipate in the next fiscal year 25
that you'll probably have a similar
request of $4.6 million to cover these
additional medical
expenses thank you for the question
um we do not because we believe that
we'll have made sign ific gains with our
primary cost driver treating hepatitis C
however and having been someone who
worked in hospital Administration versus
Corrections
um some of the forecasting changes in
Corrections we have no knowledge of what
is happening um in specific knowledge of
what is occurring in our state until of
who's coming our way until they're there
on our doorsteps an example um not
related to this particular budget item
but it's the cleanest example I can
think of we uh budget every year for
dialysis some years we spend absolutely
no dollars on dialysis some years as
like this one we get halfway through the
fiscal year and then we get a dialysis
patient who needs it three days a week
that we didn't know is coming now please
understand we' budgeted it's not related
to this request but it gives you an
example of
the difficulties the challenges in
forecasting and predicting who's coming
through our doors um that being said we
um certainly look at uh from year to
year what we're expending looking at
factors what may change that and budget
appropriately thank you thank you for
the thank you for the question thank so
much thanks Mr
chairman representative Edwards for a
question uh thank you Mr chair and and
uh represent 's question sort of
triggered this thought I it it seems to
me like we have a huge uh budget driver
in the future related to
biologics could is isn't that going to
be a a big cost driver in future budgets
and shouldn't we be expecting that
you'll be
requesting a lot more money what to what
do you think the future of biologics is
and
Corrections want to clarify um thank you
for the question I want to clarify um
when you use the term biologics can you
tell me tell us please specifically what
you're looking at and then we would love
to answer that question I I can't a
answer it very specifically but it's my
understanding that we have a new line of
drugs that are being uh almost uh
uniquely engineered for a particular
patients um medical conditions and what
their Gene code is and and so these
biologics are becoming very uh precise
and targeted and they're and
expensive
please thank you for your question uh so
what what we are seeing right now uh is
is an increase in those products but we
are also at a point where we are seeing
um equivalents of those products become
available in the marketplace um one of
the uh more recent products Humira has
had a uh a Marketplace equivalent come
out called Head Lima that product is one
of the actual cost so for what we could
treat one patient uh before on Huma we
now can treat five patients uh and we're
seeing that across the board the as
these drugs start to develop um we're
seeing more and more of these drugs
become uh or or we wouldn't call them
generics directly because they're uh
biologically designed but they're uh
equivalents to these products um and
they are significantly less expensive to
the
depart
okay we did have a motion right yes all
right had a motion on a second on item
2452 is there any further discussion
seeing none you're ready for the
question all in favor say I I oppose no
you we're left with information items
and audits any questions on information
audits
other the report submitted by HHS the
laps number was going to be recorded the
potential laps number it it hasn't been
on it's been on previous reports on the
dashboard we're looking for that I think
we we got that message to yeah we had a
discussion with the LBA about how you
know what a wild ass guess that was
right and uh they're going to try to do
better right thank you thank you thank
you welcome good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
I'm Christine Young the director of
audits for the
LBA uh we're here to present the annual
reports for the college savings plans as
you know our office retains the services
of price Waterhouse Coopers to perform
these Audits and with us from PWC is the
partner zean burn and also Monica
mespelli our state treasurer and the
trustee of the plans is here to respond
to any questions that you may have or
make any additional comments about the
Audits and with that I will turn it over
to the partner for the
presentation thank you
perfect Representatives uh it's always a
highlight of my year to come here and uh
present the results of the 529 audits
it's uh just great to see how government
really works uh behind the scenes and
it's always certainly uh one of the
highlights of my year even though it's
always cold um but nonetheless I'm here
to present the the results of the 529
plans and thankfully as again I come
here bearing good news and um and I know
we've provided the materials in advance
and I won't go Page by Page by any
manner of means but I just I just refer
you to page five and I'll just give a
highlight of the audit which which went
swimmingly um I'm have to say we got
great collaboration with the with the
team here uh trer audits we also got
great collaboration from Fidelity
Fidelity plays a a huge role in
maintaining the books and records of
transacting the part plan participant
accounts and uh giving the support we
need to provide uh our audit services
and and get us over the line um so
overall a really successful audit and
I'll just highlight a few few comments
in this page just to to round out these
are a lot of the um required
Communications I would say that we have
to talk about as part of the the close
out to the audit but by and large really
good successful audit um and just to
drill down a bit when we think about the
the execution the audit we design it and
think about it in the summer time frame
we we look at the controls of fidelity
we talk to the state we see what's
changing we look at the external Market
what's out there that would really would
change our judgment as Auditors of how
we approach the audit thankfully as we
went through the fall um and then start
getting into the work really no change
in how we we approach the audit stable
control environment stable sock ones and
they are really the reports that we rely
on at Fidelity so everything was pretty
stable from a from an execution
standpoint you know the valuation was
good the confirmation process was good
presentation disclosure was really well
well done by Fidelity and and again
great um anything we needed from the
state we got a timely and on time so we
released our audit opinions in advance
of the holidays in around December 2 1
uh 14th and the 21st so that was exactly
On Target so again no major delays at
all um and then from a from a result
standpoint we really have nothing of
significance of a negative manner to
report you um and I'll highlight no
material weaknesses so what that really
means is we we looked at the design of
the control environment both of fidelity
and the state and we made a judgment
based on our the the results of our Auto
work no real material weaknesses no
control matters that we were worrisome
that were call into question you know
future errors no errors noted no
uncorrected misstatements nothing that
we passed on from a judgment standpoint
nothing what we found that was booked by
management um and that's that's a good
result and we do spend a lot of time on
Fidelity transaction processing like I
said and and they are key cog in this
process and we certainly were able to
get everything we needed from them so we
didn't come across anything from the
first draft to the last draft to really
have significance that needed to change
and then thankfully no fraud or error so
everybody's on their best behavior and
um no non-compliance with laws and
regulations which are pretty pretty
critical for us um we do have some new
portfolios this year and that's an
important process to make sure they're
set up right in year one and and make
sure the opening NE is accurate and all
all the numbers are good so we just
highlight that there were some new areas
for this year and then and slide seven
and and eight and nine I I I think
reaffirm just under the Professional
Standards what we need to tell you but
um as I mentioned the quality financial
statements were were really good um
there's no change in the standards much
this year so that that was positive no
no no arguments no um disagreements with
management and no major difficulties in
terms of the the audit and um you know
we we do highlight in some of the
appendices you know how how we approach
audit quality as as a firm and it is
number one of what we how we try to
approach these audits um as well as some
of our written Communications but on an
overall basis it was it was a you know
pretty straightforward audit and we're
delighted to be here today to to give
the readout um to the state which is
pleasure thank questions from the
committee thank you I always look
forward to your
presentation that's why he always enjoys
coming here really
perfect and uh not not not only is it
always positive but it is articulated in
a magnificent manner
truly this is our day to appreciate an
audit the bottom Line's black it's
pretty heavy we can't beat that but
thank you so much really kudos to is for
giving for giving us you for this for
this Venture thank you thank you very
much well I'm American now so well
that's that's even that's even better
exactly but my uh my wife's
brother-in-law lives in
Belfast great place thank you thank you
Mr chairman and let us not forget that
perfectionist thank you Mr chairman um
good morning still um for the record uh
Monica mipel State Treasurer um so uh
once again I would like to thank uh Mr
burn and uh director young for their
collaboration and their work to and
obviously uh pwc's uh pwc's Team um that
did a terrific um job um completing this
audit uh Timely
and uh with clean opinions so we're very
uh pleased with the results uh once
again um I'm also um pleased to report
uh that this uh program continues to be
a very successful program in the state
um it continues to help uh New Hampshire
families and individuals around the
country to meet and achieve their
education savings goals um uh right now
the plan continues uh and Remains the
four largest in the country uh right now
we have over $24 billion in assets under
management and approximately 950,000
participant accounts um the plan
recovered from a challenging in
2022 um and but this year in 23 uh it
grew by approximately
14% um over last year so again a
successful plan um and again um in
addition to um the benefits of having a
very successful College SS program the
state also benefits uh from receiving
that administrative assessment that is
charged to 529 participants um in FIS
year 23 the state receive approximately
18.2 million uh dollars in revenue and
with that Revenue we funded
approximately 9,000 uh scholarships that
were given and granted to New Hampshire
uh students uh low-income
students um so again with the growth of
the plan and the new accounts that we
see um we hope to continue to provide
more scholarship ship uh each year um so
um again a great to great story to share
and we thank you as always for your
ongoing support so I'll be happy to
answer any questions are there any
further
questions seeing now I the clerk reminds
me we have already had the motion to
accept the report in the usual manner
anything further
um a lot of times we need the motion to
include to keep it on file and other
things so is if the the motion is proper
then we can go ahead if not we need to
modify it uh we took it back in November
because the treasur is required to
disclose that prior so you're all set
with putting it on file uh releasing
public Etc no more motions are necessary
thank you thank you very much thank you
very
much all
right I have a proposal for March 15 for
is there
any any alternative request or is that
acceptable that that's good with me I
I'm I'm looking at the first week of
April uh as as another fiscal meeting do
we have anything that
week the like April 6th or 7th whatever
usually we go to the third Friday all
right thank you so it's unlikely to be
okay all right so it will be and will be
published next um fiscal meeting March
15 10:00 in this
room anything further uh Mr Kaine
no no one has what can we expect for
audits M
Young
oh typically we have management letters
this is Christine Young the director of
audit so typically we'll have management
letters for the cafer liquor Lottery uh
turn so we'll keep it busy through the
spring if she does want to speak she
needs to move up to one of the mics yes
that's all right I heard her if there's
nothing further I'll entertain a motion
to adjourn oh wait a minut yeah so
motion to
adjourn by Senator Dallas and second by
Senator gray all in favor say I I we are
much